manger à neuf mois la petite joséphine
s'exerce à garder l'équilibré pendant
que ses parents et s'est surtout
d'équilibrer leur budget
lorsque nicolas et mégane ont appris
qu'ils auraient une petite fille la
question des frais de garde s'est
rapidement imposé on a même parlé avant
d'avoir si on avait enfin piqué si on
pouvait pas payer la garderie qu'on
considère peut-être déménager
pour faire des économies le couple a
plutôt choisi de demander l'aide de sa
famille la mère de megan a pris sa
retraite plutôt prévu et celle de
nicolas ajustera son horaire de travail
pour pouvoir s'occuper de sa petite
fille dans le milieu économique où on
est avec nos enfants qui essaient de se
payer une maison on a trouvé que cette
solution là pour l'instant elle est une
bonne solution un rapport du centre
canadien de politiques alternatives
montré que le coût médian des garderies
frôlait les 1800 dollars par mois à
toronto contre 179 $ à montréal soit
environ le tarif fixé par la province
dans les garderies subventionnées une
situation aberrante pour gilles
levasseur qui est originaire du québec
c'est une tragédie pour les familles
dans leur dernier budget les libéraux
misé gros sur un programme pancanadien
de garderie abordable 30 milliards de
dollars sur cinq ans pour offrir le
service de garde à 10 dollars par jour
partout au pays oui occupe
depuis le déclenchement des élections
les troupes de justin trudeau continue
de faire de cette promesse un élément
central de leur plateforme mais ils ne
sont pas les seuls à courtiser les
familles
le parti conservateur propose plutôt un
crédit d'impôt qui couvrirait jusqu'à 75
% des frais de gares pour certaines
familles on veut vraiment mettre en
oeuvre des programmes sociaux qui aident
les gens et le npd milite aussi pour des
garderies à 10 dollars par jour tu as
besoin d'avoir concert de cet égard
comme si nécessaire pour ce jeune papa
torontois les garderies abordables sont
l'enjeu principal de cette campagne
électorale si on le fait pour te tuer
on va le faire un jour depuis plus
longtemps qu'on attend le plus que ça un
effet les faces la société
cet analyste à la chambre de commerce de
l'ontario s'est intéressée à l'impact de
la pandémie sur la participation des
femmes au marché du travail elle affirme
que la problématique des garderies
abordable est également crucial pour les
entreprises
même écho chez cette sociologue qui
espère que cette élection permettrait de
régler la question une fois pour toutes
mais l'expert souligne qui ne suffira
pas qu'ottawa promettent d'investir
en double et nicolas et mégane affirme
que le coût des garderies influencera
leur décision lorsque viendra le temps
d'aller aux urnes qu'importe le résultat
des élections joséphine elle passera
l'hiver sous le regard attentif de ses
grand mères et si à ce métier radio
canada toronto